[Music]
my name is Lily Coulson and I'm 18 years
old
these are my three best friends mmm
Beck's and Sarah
and this is the story of how my town
Salem lost its mind well let's start at
the beginning
dude the principal got hacked
I'll give him like five days before he
commits suicide I'm sorry I just don't
have any sympathy for people that get
hacked for real there's two types of
people in this world people that have
come to terms with privacy is just dead
then there's the old people that are
still trying to fight it what do you
have to hide anyway little a million
nudes super gross porn history and like
super pervy tax about almost everyone at
this school me2 me3 i think it was some
like socially conscious a Chilean tea
hacker guy I live for this type of
scandal to be honest looks like half a
salem just got hacked there's nothing
anybody can do to get these videos down
117 thousand people's texts and emails
got leaked people get really weird
who sees a naked photo of a girl and
their first thought is yo I gotta kill
this brawl way more people than you
think
[Applause]
this is your world you built this
don't take your head out on me I just
got here
may kill me but she can't kill us all
you
[Music]
you